what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we're going to talk about how
Dr Doom should replace Kang in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so the Talk of
the Town is that Marvel Studios is
parted ways with Jonathan Majors
following the conclusion of his trial
and Avengers cane Dynasty has reportedly
been renamed to Avengers 5 so it looks
as though they're walking away from the
whole thing about Kang so here's my idea
about Dr Doom right so here's the thing
Dr Doom in order for this Theory to make
sense there's a couple of amazing things
we need to talk about with Dr Doom first
number one this guy has no qualms wiping
out entire universes and I'm not talking
about you know the ending of Avengers
and New Avengers and the death of the
Multiverse is inevitable and Secret Wars
happens because Dr Doom is just trying
to save what he can where he can no no
no no in Christopher kwells Dr Doom's
solo series he comes across an alternate
reality version of himself who's like
this really kind guy and gave away all
his wealth and status and it's just
become like this huge philanthropist and
Dr Doom's like that guy sucks and I
would never do that this guy is a poor
representation of me and honestly he's
imparing so what does Dr Doom do he
wipes out his entire reality literally
he just dusts the whole universe and
leaves and it's just one of the most
baller things that Dr Doom's done so
that guy has no quals with doing that
the other part of this is that Dr Doom
genuinely believes he's smarter than
everybody else he's not we learned that
at the end of Secret Wars 2015 secretly
he knows that Reed Richards is smarter
than him and a better man than him but
his arrogance kind of prevents him from
being able to believe that so with those
two things under our belt the stage is
set for this Theory to make sense so
first and foremost Dr Doom is one of the
only people in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe who knows about the King
Dynasty the only other people who know
about this are of course the obvious
choices the TVA Sylvie who's out there
somewhere Janet vany has probably talked
to like the entirety of the cast of
quantum Mania and kind of spilled the
beans about everything regarding Kang
and what she knew about the council and
like that's really it the only other
person out there in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe who knows about the King
Dynasty who's not been revealed is Reed
Richards and I have a whole theory about
him if you guys are interested in that
then let me know down in the comment
section but in effect Dr Doom here
learns about Kang the Conqueror and you
could do this in any number of ways
because in Marvel Comics King the
Conqueror is a descendant of presumably
Dr Doom I don't think it's actually been
confirmed in Marvel maybe it was in a
Solo series I can't remember off the top
of my head but Nathaniel Richards right
Kane the Conqueror is descended from
either Reed Richards or Dr Doom I don't
think Marvel's really been absolutely
clear on that but you could say that
Doom learns about Kang and then in turn
Kang's like you know we're planning
something big or or something on those
lines but alludes to the idea of the
King Dynasty but doesn't actually give
him the information that he needs but
Doom figures out quite readily that the
King Dynasty represents a multiversal
threat and so in turn Doom basically
tracks down the can Dynasty and the way
he does this is by jumping from one
Universe to the next and going through
the Multiverse and finding these
variants of Kang not a whole ton of them
but like a few of them now the reason
why I'm going in this direction is
because this is basically what happened
in Avengers and New Avengers which is
the story that directly Segways into
Secret Wars 2015 and we know that
Avengers Secret Wars from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is going to be a
combination of Secret Wars from 1984 and
the 2015 story so it dovetails in quite
nicely but basically Doom travels to the
Multiverse and comes across a few
different variants of Kang and in doing
so tortures them or does whatever he has
to do to gain information and eventually
learns about the King Dynasty now you
might be asking yourself wouldn't the
TVA track him down because he's like
traveling to the Multiverse when he's
not supposed to I mean maybe but Dr Doom
did it and the TVA never showed up on
his doorstep so we can just say it's
cool when Dr Doom does it so the thing
about this is that once Doom figures out
what's going on once he realizes that
the King Dynasty itself is an
existential threat to the entirety of
the Multiverse Dr Doom wipes them all
out and then he metaphorically ascends
the throne and is like it's my time now
thus we basically get the age of Doom
from that really awesome Instagram art
or we say it's like you know Avengers
Doom war or whatever it is or just call
it secret Wars right and they just have
like Doom's face plastered all over the
poster for it however it is that you
want to make it look but to me this
works I mean it's not a perfect Theory
right I mean it's it's not like
foolproof I mean I know how much you
guys love punching holes in theories
that I have so I'm sure you'll do your
due diligence but the thing about this
is that Doom is a guy who for a few
different reasons would actually embark
on this campaign the first is that being
as arrogant as he is he would genuinely
believe he's the only person out there
who is smart enough capable enough and
powerful enough to deal with this threat
and you could even back this argument up
by saying The Avengers don't really
exists anymore and even the Avengers
themselves I mean let's be honest with
ourselves right like The Avengers are
cool the first movie was awesome we all
love being in the movie theater if that
team had fought Dr Doom he would have
slapped them around like like when Hulk
smacked around Loki right I mean Doom
would have just Doom would have clapped
The Avengers cheeks in no uncertain
terms my friend that's exactly what
would have happened right it would have
just been absolutely amazing but the
thing about it is that with their being
no real Avengers team who else is going
to do it right Reed Richard in the
Fantastic 4 they're not on Earth they're
effectively lost in the Multiverse so
how are they going to deal with the
threat so even if there was somebody out
there who is capable enough in Doom's
eyes to handle this I.E Reed Richards
they're not here right so what's going
to happen right there's not really going
to be any way for anybody to step in and
do anything the other reason why this
works is because Dr Doom is always on a
mad quest for power he's always trying
to attain absolute power and there's two
motivations for this the original
motivation is that Dr Doom's mom had
sold her soul to Mesto in order to gain
power and then when she died meiso
collected her soul and every year he
would basically go to mephisto's realm
he would fight him try to free his mom's
Soul it would never work and then it
happened in Triumph and torment when him
and Dr Doom teamed up and they basically
won we're not invoking mefisto here as
cool as it would be to see him that's
not going to be the case the other thing
about this is in Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic 4 I don't remember which issue
it was but one of the things that was
specified by the Council of reeds is
that Doom's quest for power is
insatiable right even after undergoing
his quest and freeing his mom's Soul he
will always try to attain absolute power
there's no way to stop him that's the
reason why the Council of reeds had just
lobotomized like 110 versions of Dr Doom
right they were all just under the
Citadel just saying Doom right I mean
they just shut their brains down right
they're higher COG function reduce him
to a you know basic state but like Doom
is always hunting for power what better
way than to like have Dr Doom just
appear in the MCU then by wiping out the
King Dynasty and going forward from
there now people will say but Rob Dr
Doom needs to be built up to you can't
just throw him into the MCU because
reasons that's the biggest bunch of
malarkey ever if Dr Doom appeared in a
post-credit scene like right now you
would absolutely lose your minds right
like you would freak out you would you
wouldn't be sitting there thinking well
this post credit scene is terrible
because Dr Doom needs to be built up to
no you would jump out of your chair
popcorn would go flying your drink would
fall off your lab and spill on the
ground and you'd be jumping up and down
taking to Twitter and his name would be
trending for 3 weeks so here's the thing
man like let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section right like
this doesn't it's not a perfect Theory
doesn't need to be perfect just kind of
my general idea for putting Doom in the
MCU but if you guys want to get caught
up on Avengers and New Avengers you
absolutely need to make sure you click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all later peace